hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
high-definition video and today is the
beginning of a big series for mkbhd so
thanks to the help of a lot of you on
YouTube and on Twitter
we've come to notice that the mkbhd
YouTube channel are all I guess partner
channels or maybe even every channel
have a new feature called Google
moderator this is powered by Google
moderator and it allows people to
actually make suggestions ask questions
or use ideas to post them to people's
channels so what I featured at the very
top of my channel I'm going to leave it
above my videos is a Google moderator
and what we're going to do is at the end
of every single week the suggestion on
the top of the moderator widget on my
channel that has the most thumbs up is
going to win so that's the video that
I'll be doing for that week so this
one's actually does end at I guess I'll
put it at Friday at midnight so you guys
can actually submit all your ideas and
questions software videos Android videos
screencasts reviews hardware stuff that
I haven't reviewed yet anything you'd
like to see will be submitted here
obviously things that are inappropriate
will be deleted we've got 250 characters
and you can even attach one of your own
videos and if I see it and approve it
all your friends can vote on it so be
sure to get your friends to come to this
channel and vote on it now it's sorted
automatically about what's hot so you'll
see what has the most thumbs up and
we'll try to get the most the most
thumbs up on a video or a suggestion
will be submitted and that will
definitely work on that video that
weekend and whoever's idea gets the most
thumbs up will definitely get a shout
out at the beginning of the video they
submitted so you can check out the
description of it and of course visit my
channel page for more information and
that's basically the the gist of Google
moderator I'll definitely be posting a
tutorial on how to create your own
Google moderator for your own channel in
the near future so again thanks for
checking this out and go ahead and
submit your ideas for a new mkbhd video
until then I'll talk to you guys the
next one thanks for watching this quick
video peace